today's video is kindly sponsored by
brightsellers a monthly wine club that
matches you with wine you'll love find
out more later on hey 42 here with its
stunning fjords isolated glaciers and
forest covered mountains norway is one
of the world's premier hiking
destinations
it's the perfect place to immerse
yourself in nature and simply get away
from it all
this picture here for example was taken
in isdalen a valley just outside the
city of bergen it's an idyllic spot by
all accounts notice the mountains the
trees the moss-covered rocks the
horrifically charred remains of a human
corpse
wait what
okay so i haven't actually hidden an
extremely well camouflaged dead person
in this image
but on the 29th of november 1970 in this
exact spot the badly burnt remains of a
young woman were found by a 12 year old
girl who was out for a relaxing show
with her father and elder sister
the scene the young family stumbled upon
was beyond disturbing the scorched body
lay flat on its back amongst the rocks
its arms outstretched as though fending
off an unseen attacker
that kind of pose is common amongst
bodies that have been exposed to fire as
the extreme heat causes muscle and body
tissues to shrivel up warping the limbs
but it's chilling all the same it was
impossible to say who the woman was her
clothes were all but burnt away and her
blackened face was unrecognizable
to tell the truth
she hardly even looked human
when the badly shaken family reported
their grisly fine to police later that
day an investigation was launched at
once
though nobody knew it at the time a
decades-long quest to solve one of the
greatest mysteries in modern history
had just begun
now i love cooking and i especially love
drinking wine whilst i'm doing it one of
life's greatest pleasures for me is
opening a new bottle of red and finding
out it's perfect for my taste buds and
that's exactly why i like bright cellars
bright cellars is a wine box experience
that matches you to wines from all over
the world curated to your palette bright
sellers does all this by giving you a
quick and simple seven question quiz
with fun questions like what's your
favorite chocolate
this will then outline your taste
preferences and make sure they deliver
wines that you're guaranteed to love but
it's not just about drinking the wine
what i love most is that you can easily
educate yourself on the wines you're
drinking thanks to the wine education
cards that come with every bottle bright
cellars is a five-star experience for me
i think their wines service
personalization convenience and
sustainability are just all unbeatable
bright sellers have been extremely
generous and they're offering my viewers
60 off your first four bottle box
all you need to do is follow the link in
the description to take the quiz and get
started today
the first thing officers from the bergen
police force noticed when they reached a
scene was that there was a surprisingly
large amount of evidence to collect an
umbrella two melted plastic bottles
several pieces of jewelry a watch a
purse a matchbox a pair of rubber boots
some nylon stockings and many other odds
and ends most of these probably sound
like fairly normal things for a woman to
have been wearing or carrying on a hike
in the mountains
but that was the funny thing
she had been neither wearing nor
carrying any of them
they'd been carefully arranged around
her body as though part of some weird
ritual or ceremony
considering the state of her face the
first port of call was to figure out who
the deceased actually was no
identification was found on or near the
body
but that wasn't all that surprising it
might easily have been consumed in the
fire
what
was surprising was the fact that someone
had carefully snipped all the labels out
of the clothing that had survived the
inferno
pretty much the only remaining clue as
to who the woman might have been was her
fingerprints
which luckily had survived the fire
intact
a detail that would later prove crucial
unable to put a name on the badly burnt
face the investigation simply referred
to the woman by her case number
134-70
but as it became increasingly clear that
identifying the woman was going to be
one hell of a challenge an unofficial
name was chosen
the isdel woman
days passed as the evidence was backed
and the body removed from the hillside
in preparation for autopsy
but the investigation turned up pretty
much
nothing
nobody came forward to report a loved
one or friend missing and nobody seemed
to have seen or heard anything out of
the ordinary in the mountains around
bergen
whoever the isdal woman was
nobody appeared to have noticed she
disappeared
the first real progress in the case came
when two suitcases were found in the
left luggage section at the bergen
railway station
inside one of the bags was a pair of
sunglasses
and on one of the lenses
fingerprints
they matched the istyl woman's exactly
but instead of answers the contents of
the suitcase only seemed to raise more
questions amongst a woman's possessions
were clothes shoes several wigs of
different hair colours four kinds of
currency makeup some prescription skin
cream several maps a pair of glasses
with non-prescription lenses
and what appeared to be a kind of coded
note or cipher as had been the case with
the items found alongside the iste
woman's body
someone presumably the woman herself had
gone to the trouble of removing all
identifying information from everything
in the cases there were no labels in the
clothes
or branding stickers on any of the
cosmetics even the prescription label on
the skin cream had been systematically
scratched off
great care had been taken to thoroughly
anonymize every single item in both
cases
all except
for one
a plastic bag bearing the name of a shoe
shop in the city of stavenger which lies
about 150 kilometers to the south of
bergen as far as leads go it wasn't a
bad one but by the standards of this
particular case it was positively
spectacular it paid off too because it
turned out that the shoe shop owner's
son had recently sold a pair of boots
exactly like those found by the easter
woman's body to a young woman even
better he remembered the woman well and
was able to give a detailed description
of her appearance
young attractive dark-haired along with
several other valuable details like the
fact she was foreign and had spoken to
him in english with a thick accent
it was to break through the
investigation he'd been waiting for and
from there the pieces began to fall into
place quickly a woman matching that
description had stayed in the nearby
saints viven hotel and there more traces
of the isle woman were found
all foreigners staying in hotels in
norway at the time were required to fill
in a registration form
and a quick check of the hotel's records
provided the woman's name and
nationality
vanilla lodge
belgium
but just as it seemed the mystery of the
isle woman's identity had been solved
there was a setback according to the
authorities in belgium
vanilla lodge didn't exist
it was a frustrating discovery but
perhaps not all together surprising
after all going by the contents of her
suitcases the isdal woman had been no
mere tourist and for whatever reason she
seemed to have gone to great lengths to
keep her real identity secret
and anyway the trip to stavanger hadn't
been wasted
not only did norwegian detectives on the
case now have a detailed description of
the isdel woman they also had a sample
of her handwriting using that sample
forensic handwriting experts began to
search hotel records across the whole of
norway for matches
and it wasn't long before they started
to get hits
lots of them
it turned out that the isdal woman
whoever she was had been a busy lady in
the lead up to her untimely death
traveling all over norway and staying in
at least nine different hotels using
seven fake identities
widening the net to hotels across europe
it seems she'd also recently spent time
in paris and possibly rome too
through interviews with staff at the
various norwegian hotels she'd visited
detectives slowly began to build a
picture of who this unknown jet setter
might have been the isdal woman was
invariably described as sophisticated
stylish and well-dressed by all those
who remembered her she'd been heard
speaking several languages including
english french german and flemish and
several people noted that she mostly
kept to herself
and that she often seemed a little
guarded perhaps even on edge
her behavior was strange too she paid
for everything in cash even when large
sums were involved and often requested a
change of rooms not long after checking
in to a new hotel
sometimes more than once
around this time the force back in
bergen finally cracked the encoded
message that had been found in the
woman's luggage
but the whole thing turned out to be a
bit of a letdown in fact far from
providing key details that might help
investigators solve the case
the note turned out to contain
information they'd already pieced
together from the various hotel
registration forms they collected
the super secret cipher was nothing more
than a simple travel itinerary written
in a kind of shorthand
the numbers represented dates and the
letters represented cities and the
months in which they were visited
hardly the handiwork of a master spy
by mid-december 1970 the results of the
autopsy were back and they were both
disturbing and surprising disturbing
because soot found in the istal woman's
lungs
showed that she'd still been alive as
she burnt and surprising because it
wasn't only the fire that killed her
according to the coroner alongside
carbon monoxide poisoning caused by the
fumes from her own burning body
the ister woman's death was also partly
caused by the combined effect of more
than 50 sleeping pills found partly
digested in her stomach
the presence of the sleeping pills was
unexpected but it was also something of
a lifeline for the investigation
they still had no idea who the woman was
but they were now pretty sure who'd
killed her because if the isle woman had
died with a belly full of prescription
drugs
that probably meant only one thing
suicide as you can probably imagine
plenty of people were unhappy with that
verdict
suicide by self-immolation is
practically unheard of and on the rare
occasions it does happen it's almost
invariably carried out somewhere very
public in order to make a political
statement
without putting too fine a point on it
it's an absolutely horrific way to go
not one many people would willingly
choose
even if they did dose up on sleeping
pills beforehand
even so the istal woman's death was
officially deemed a suicide and the case
was closed in early 1971
just months after the body had first
been discovered
in the decades since literally thousands
of journalists amateur sleuths and crime
writers have poured over the details of
the isle woman's death searching for new
clues and coming up with their own
theories as to who she was and what
really happened on that desolate
mountainside near bergen in 1970 the
most popular theory is that the isdal
woman was a spy of some kind probably
for the soviets or maybe the israelis
considering what i've told you about the
case so far i'm going to go ahead and
guess you might have seen that one
coming
the fake identities the outfits that
boarded on disguises the strange
behavior in hotels moving from room to
room
it's a pretty compelling theory and it
turns out there's actually even more
evidence to back it up because whilst it
was never publicly acknowledged at the
time the official investigation into the
istal woman's death also explored the
idea she may have been a spy the cold
war was in full swing at the time and it
was no secret that soviets by activity
in norway was fairly intense
not only does norway share a border with
russia the norwegians were also in the
process of developing an advanced
anti-ship missile called the penguin
i know very frightening
and it's well documented that certain
foreign powers were keen to learn more
about this new weapon
recently declassified documents show
that the iste woman's movements around
norway
roughly coincided with scheduled penguin
weapons tests along the country's west
coast
and at least one witness claims to have
seen a woman matching her description
observing the tests
staff from one of the hotels she stayed
in also claims to have seen her meet
with a naval officer
intriguingly some of the police officers
involved in the investigation claimed to
have met with resistance when pursuing
certain leads in the case particularly
those related to the idea that the isdal
woman was a spy it was almost as though
somewhere in the halls of power
somebody was keen to keep the whole
thing quiet
so could it be that the israel woman was
a spy whose cover was blown was she
killed by rival operatives for the
dangerous secrets she'd uncovered in her
work in 2005 a bergen resident came
forward claiming to have seen someone
matching the ista woman's description
heading into the mountains near the city
with two men in pursuit he says the
woman seemed to be about to speak to him
but after glancing the men behind her
she changed her mind
put all this together and it certainly
paints a convincing picture
but
as you would expect from one of the most
mysterious cases in recent history
things aren't quite so simple as that
for starters expert opinion is split on
whether or not the isle woman could even
have been a spy in the first place
some fairly heavy hitters in the
espionage world have spent some time
looking into the case including at least
one xkgb spy and norway's most famous
spy catcher
and they don't seem to be able to agree
on the likelihood that the mysterious
woman was a foreign agent
that might come as a bit of a surprise
but when you think about it some of her
actions weren't actually very spy-like
at all
take her apparent meticulousness and
sniffing the labels out of her clothes
and removing them from all her other
possessions
that might sound like spy school 101
stuff
but is it really after all you'd expect
any spy worth his soul to simply wear
clothes that matched his cover story the
isdal woman was a foreigner in norway
she wasn't trying to pass herself off as
norwegian
she could have worn clothes from pretty
much anywhere without anyone butting an
eyelid and the same goes for her
cosmetics and the other items she
carried
you could argue that removing all the
labels was far more suspicious than a
belgian woman owning belgium face cream
and wearing belgian clothes then there
were her multiple aliases in both bergen
and stavenger the istel woman used
different identities in different hotels
within the same city just a few days
apart which seems like an entirely
unnecessary risk for an undercover
operative to take
these aren't particularly big cities
even today and people working in the
hotel trade often have contacts in other
hotels
what if someone had realized that the
same stylish foreigner was checking into
different hotels using different names
all over the city
what isn't entirely clear is whether the
israel woman had official documents to
back up her identities
none were ever found and it may just be
that she dreamt the aliases up all by
herself
the forms were filled out in her own
handwriting after all so there's no
guarantee she was asked to provide her
passport to hotel staff there's no
denying that the isdal woman's
activities were strange but whether or
not they match those of a professional
spy
is debatable but if not a spy then what
could possibly explain the strange
details of the case some people believe
the is still a woman may have been some
kind of high level escort or prostitute
that would fit with the hotel visits and
perhaps even the different identities
she was seen with various men including
important ones and the wigs and other
outfits found in her suitcases may have
been for the benefit of clients with
differing tastes you could even argue
that the resistance detectives met
during the investigation
came from one of her powerful clients
who was keen to keep his naughty secrets
under wraps
others think the isdal woman might have
been involved in organized crime or was
perhaps an international art thief
the problem with most of these alternate
theories is that there's no hard
evidence to back them up
there's also the issue that none of the
theories i've mentioned so far including
the spy theory explain the incredibly
strange circumstances of the isle
woman's death
most people discount the official
version of events that the isthil woman
committed suicide partly because of the
way she died
as i've said self-immolation is an
incredibly rare way to kill yourself but
something that's also often overlooked
in this case is the fact that it's also
a pretty bloody weird way to murder
someone
i'm no hitman
obviously but i'm guessing that forcing
someone to swallow more than 50 sleeping
pills against their will is probably
pretty tricky
and even if you could do it
why bother the obvious answer to that
question is to make a murder look like a
suicide but if that was the aim
why set the victim on fire afterwards
if the isdi woman was a spy why was she
just killed in such a strange way and
then just left on a mountainside where
someone was bound to find her sooner or
later
it's thought that there was almost a
week between her death and the discovery
of her body
more than enough time to dispose of the
evidence
the truth is for now nobody has really
managed to come up with compelling
answers to these questions
and none of the theories so far proposed
seem capable of accounting for all the
cases unusual details
it isn't completely crazy to suggest
that the conclusion the official
investigation reached more than 50 years
ago that the isle woman committed
suicide does a good job as any theory of
explaining the evidence
but perhaps the details of this case are
so insane because only insanity itself
can actually account for them
most people look at the istal woman's
actions the fastidious removal of all
identifying information from her
possessions
the multiple identities the odd habit of
changing hotel rooms and think spy
but you don't have to squint all that
hard to see those same actions through
the lens of mental illness was the isle
woman simply a disturbed individual
paranoid and alone
maybe by taking sleeping pills then
dousing herself in petrol and lighting a
match
she was simply eliminating one last
piece of the fractured identity she so
desperately wanted to hide
much like all the other theories it's
hard to argue that this one fits all the
facts either the isdal woman clearly had
money means and the wherewithal to take
herself around norway and europe doing
whatever it was she was doing
then there are the eyewitness accounts
placing her in conversation with various
important people it's hard to see how
they might have happened if she was
living out some grand delusion
if you're finding it hard to know what
the hell to believe right now i don't
blame you it's almost as though there's
some key piece of evidence missing from
the case some unifying clue that if
found would give new meaning to the
confusing details of the story
that just don't seem to align no matter
how you choose to jiggle them around
as for whether that clue will ever be
found well there's every reason to hope
so
the isdal woman's case may be more than
50 years old but it was officially
reopened back in 2016
and every so often new evidence comes to
light much of that evidence centers on
the one piece of the isle woman's body
that remained above ground after her
burial in 1971. her jawbone
the jawbone is significant because along
with her fingerprints it represents a
second piece of identifying information
the fire didn't destroy
the is the woman had some seriously
weird looking dental work done including
14 fillings several gold crowns and a
solid gold tooth
back in the 70s it was hoped a dentist
might recognize his handiwork in a
deceased woman's jaw and come forward
but nobody ever did
today it's hoped that the jawbone along
with the tissue samples taken during the
ista woman's autopsy
might be used to unlock the secrets of
her identity at its most fundamental
level using her genetic information and
other data locked away in her remains
analysis has so far revealed that she
was most likely born in norenburg
germany sometime around 1930 and that
she probably moved to the france-germany
border as a child in 2019 the dna doe
project a pioneering forensic genealogy
not-for-profit showed an interest in
taking on the case the project which
launched in 2017 has already helped
identify a remarkable number of unknown
people in cases fought to be essentially
unsolvable
by tracking down their living relatives
could the istal woman be next
let's hope so
thanks for watching